[Music]
more evidence tonight that it's always
the people you most suspect
andrew cuomo governor of new york is
every bit the creep you thought he was
and more he talks like a mafia leader
and he acts like one
11 sexual harassment claims against him
public today if you're interested go
over to cnn right now and watch
jeffrey tubin of all people talk about
how
creepy governor cuomo is because this
country just couldn't get better
we're gonna have a lot more on that in
just a minute
but first tonight welcome to tucker
carlson tonight coming to you from
budapest
hungary last summer as the covid
pandemic rage throughout the united
states people who still read the new
york times
began to notice something very strange
happening at the paper
hundreds of articles that had appeared
there going back nearly a decade
suddenly vanished they disappeared
there's no way to find them
nothing like this had ever happened the
new york times considers itself very
self-consciously a living historical
record
the paper maintains meticulous
searchable archives going back to before
the civil war to 1851.
yet last august a huge number of
articles
just disappeared so what was in those
articles
we know the answer because a handful of
history-minded readers preserved them
when they first appeared every one of
them was a propaganda piece
paid for by the chinese communist party
all designed to look like news articles
you're seeing one of them on your screen
right now it reads china watch
d.o.u islands belong to china that's the
headline
now why would the new york times
america's paper of record
print propaganda from a totalitarian
regime and pretend it was a news article
well for money financial filings showed
the new york times made more than a
hundred thousand dollars a
month from this garbage those payments
were not disclosed at the time they were
hidden from new york times readers
they were only uncovered after the fact
by the washington free beacon
and the times wasn't the only news
organization that did this that took
money from the chinese communist party
since 2016 the chinese communist party
paid 20 million dollars to outlets like
the los angeles times the chicago
tribune
and the washington post twitter which
now operates as a publisher
also receives received checks from the
chinese government totaling hundreds of
thousands of dollars
now these arrangements as we said
continued for years and then last summer
they stopped abruptly the new york times
tried to hide the evidence that any of
it ever happened
but why the new york times won't say
when we asked
we do not discuss revenue beyond what is
in our quarterly earnings report a
spokesman told us this morning
so we kept looking but first here's some
context for what the new york times did
this is what mainstream news coverage in
the united states looked like for most
of last year as you watch it
see if you can tell the difference
between this and what you might see on
chinese state
television the president referred to the
coronavirus as a quote
foreign virus and i think it's going to
smack uh it's going to come across to a
lot of americans as smacking of
xenophobia xenophobic wartime trump
where he thinks the only path now
is to basically declare the virus public
enemy number one
painted in somewhat racist terms the
xenophobia and the racism in outbreak is
such a common thing
and it is incredibly dangerous it is
problematic and it is scary and i just
really want to call that out
why do you keep calling this the chinese
virus
why do you keep using this a lot of
people say it's racist
it's not racist at all no not at all it
comes from
china that's why
so as this virus emerged from central
china
to kill americans in huge numbers and
people throughout the west
news organizations in this country made
the same aggressively pro-china noises
almost all of them
politico for example hired a full-time
china shill
called david wartime to write articles
with headlines like this quote
the verdict is in china has outperformed
while the once respected
american system has disastrously
faltered
now as you read that once again you
wonder how is that different from what
the chinese would write about themselves
well it's not different the american
media were especially hysterical on the
question
of where the coronavirus came from under
no
circumstances were you allowed to
entertain the possibility
that that coronavirus coveted 19 could
have come from a lab in wuhan china
that was a conspiracy theory all the
footage you're about to see
is from early 2020. former cdc director
robert redfield
told our own sanjay gupta in a new cnn
documentary
that he believes covet 19 originated
from
a lab in wuhan even though obviously
there has been no formal evidence to
support the theory
you know the lab league theory doesn't
seem like a plausible theory unless you
aggregate the biggest collection of
coronaviruses and put them in a lab the
theory that the virus originated
in a lab in wuhan china but tonight dr
anthony fauci tells national geographic
that quote
this virus could not have been
artificially
or deliberately manipulated both
scientists and the u.s intelligence
community agree
that this coronavirus was not man-made
that is not a possibility it it came
from a
natural source it didn't come from a lab
a lot of people on the right love that
phrase escape from the lab because it
sounds like something from marvel movie
or comic book it sounds like they are
talking about
a man-made virus that china was
weaponizing
that got out of control
so the rachel maddow impersonator didn't
believe it but it wasn't just
dumb people on cable news that was
anthony fauci who was in charge of the
us government's coveted response
that was scott gottlieb who ran the fda
these are people in positions of
authority who are respected as
scientists whose word carries great
moral weight
and they all lied the new york times led
the way on this
a recent piece on unheard.com
deconstructs the new york times's role
in the propaganda effort on behalf of
china
beginning in the winter of last year at
the very beginning of the outbreak of
covet
the times confidently dismissed the lab
leak hypothesis as a quote
fringe theory in other words only
lunatics believe it
the new york times's reporter called the
theory quote the kind of conspiracy
once reserved for the tin foil hatters
you're a nut case if you think it's
possible
then a few weeks later the paper
published an op-ed by peter dasik
the virologist paid by tony fauci to
experiment on bat coronaviruses
talk about a conflict of interest so
dasic needless to say
denied that the virus could have come
from any lab he was funding
he knew better instead dasig blamed the
pandemic and we're quoting now
on road building deforestation land
clearing and agricultural development
in other words he blamed it on poor
people as 2020 continued lies like this
became less and less tenable they were
more
obviously untrue people started to
notice that a level 4 virology lab one
of few in the world
in wuhan was conducting dangerous
experiments on bat chronoviruses with
fewer safeguards than typical dentists
office has in the united states
they also noticed that tony fauci was
helping to pay for those experiments
and that's when the times decided it had
to delete those articles from its
archives
two high-level employees at the new york
times confirmed to the spectator in
london
that the paper stopped any investigation
into evidence that the chronovirus had
emerged from that lab in wuhan
quote in early 2020 said one
whistleblower
i suggested to a senior editor at the
paper that we investigate the origins of
covid19
i was told it was dangerous to run a
piece about the origins of the
coronavirus
there was resistance to running anything
that could suggest that covid19 was
man-made
or had leaked accidentally from a lab
it was untouchable everywhere said
another time source to the spectator
the fact that trump embraced it of
course
also made it a no-go according to the
whistleblowers though the biggest factor
wasn't politics
the biggest factor was the fact that the
new york times was taking money from the
communist chinese government
so they killed a story a story which by
the way was not a conspiracy theory at
all
but entirely real the house foreign
affairs committee just released a report
suggesting the coronavirus
first escaped from that lab in wuhan
much
earlier than we thought way back in
mid-september of 2019
now at the time athletes from around the
world
were in wuhan they arrived several weeks
later to compete in international games
many of them brought covet home with
them
now why didn't we know this until now
well because of a
massive and coordinated lying campaign
on behalf
of the government of china the foreign
affairs committee identifies peter dazek
who irony of einer's ironies is still by
the way
used by the washington post as an
authority
on the origin of covid they described
him as quote
the public face of a chinese communist
party disinformation campaign
designed to suppress public discussion
about a potential lab leak
end quote the committee discovered
evidence that the wuhan institute of
virology
sought bids for two contracts in
september of 2019
that was around the time the coronavirus
began to spread one of those contracts
was for something called a quote
security service procurement project and
it was issued on september 12th
now september 12th was the very same day
that the wuhan lab
abruptly took its entire virus database
offline then just four days later
the wuhan lab announced another contract
competition
this time the contract was for a 600
million dollar
effort to completely renovate the lab's
air conditioning system
now why would the wuhan institute of
virology want to replace its
air conditioning system
well just like the times dispatches from
the beijing bureau
all evidence of those contracts has now
been wiped from the website of china's
finance ministry
what does this add up to john ratcliffe
is the former director of national
intelligence in this country he just
wrote an
op-ed on foxnews.com that includes this
assessment quote
i had access to all of the us
government's most sensitive intelligence
related to the
pandemic my informed opinion is that the
lab leak theory isn't just a
possibility at the very least it is more
like a probability
if not very close to a certainty hey
sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else